arm the teachers like all the teachers
yeah so so to your earlier question is
like what's a solution that won't work
the problem with that is
the the problem with that is the details
of any solution you take any one of
these Solutions and there's certain
details that would make it better and
some details if you don't include them
are going to make it a disaster like you
just throw weapons into every classroom
with random people that haven't been
trained you you that's that's going to
be a problem
right because you've got teachers that
are that are that might go crazy right
there's all kinds of things going on so
you take any of these Solutions and you
take it to a certain extent I mean some
of the some of the ways of looking at
things can be so different depending on
who you are
that
like what's the term they use reasonable
gun control reasonable gun control means
completely different things to different
people depending on who you are and what
your background is